NASA estimates a total solar eclipse
happens where you live on average of
once every 375 years as we've been
reporting much of North America is
preparing for today's rare Eclipse the
path of totality stretches across the
u.s. from Oregon to South Carolina
Bill Nye joins us from where he will
watch in beatriz Nebraska at the
homestead National Monument he is a
scientist author and CEO of the
Planetary Society good morning and he is
waving to all of us
good morning how are you fabulous so a
beautiful day here yeah I understand
this is only the second time that you've
seen the total solar eclipse yeah second
time I've really been under it in the
paths yeah I've been to I've seen some
partials over the years but it's a very
exciting thing you guys it's going right
across the world's third most populous
country with an interstate highway
system people who really want to get in
the path of the Eclipse can so it's an
exciting year and I hope this reminds
everybody that the importance of science
yeah we can predict this eclipse within
fractions of a second and that is
because of astronomy that's because of
science so bill how do you make the most
of it I've heard anywhere from a minute
to 42 seconds to two minutes and 38
seconds how should we make the most of
this so I just recommend two things to
everybody first of all if for some
reason you don't have official size and
weight Eclipse viewing glasses you can
take a look at the Eclipse through a
traditional pinhole viewer and you can
make a pinhole viewer from a cereal box
what you do cut a hole on the top cut a
hole here put a white piece of paper
inside the box and everybody well we
call it a pinhole viewer we're not
kidding make the hole in the aluminum
foil with a pin or another common object
like this this is a paper clip it may be
familiar and then then the light will
pass through the pinhole and there's a
remarkable effect or the wave nature of
light where you get a very sharp image
of a bright object you can try it right
now before the Eclipse shows up with a
lamp in your room or if they're in the
television set you
these fabulous LED sources and you can
look at the eclipses through the pinhole
onto a white screen and you can see the
moon cover the Sun then when the moon
does cover the Sun you can look right at
it now you know the myth of the pirate
with the eyepatch yeah that's probably
and then one great myth could be that
pirates who'd had primitive navigation
instruments every day would have to
stare right at the Sun for a few minutes
to get their positions on the Earth's
surface and so by doing that you ruin
your eyesight the trouble with an
eclipse the Sun is still the Sun
everybody the trouble with an eclipse is
you just want to stare at it if you
stare at the Sun for five or six minutes
it's hard on you so it's an exciting
thing the other thing to just remind
everybody we all want to take pictures
we all want to get our phones out and
take a picture the phones are not really
ideal for taking pictures of the Sun
just try to be in the moment just try to
remember where you were what was going
on when you saw this happen and then we
encourage everybody to look at the
ground look at your surroundings because
you won't see this most of the time you
if things go really well there's the
mountains on the moon create what we
call these beads of light they're named
after a British astronomer named Bailey
Bailey's bees bees and you're seeing
actually imperfections in the lunar
surface all the way down here on earth
it's really amazing really quickly the
billy-oh took a military telescope and
said that moons not a perfect circle and
play put him in prison I'm going if can
a blind person feel the eclipse is that
does the temperature change that
dramatically oh yeah a couple of things
happen first of all it gets dark you can
see the sky you can see stars and it
gets a little bit cool for a few minutes
and then you'll hear birds they act like
it's an insects act like it's nighttime
but it's the middle of the day so it's
really a striking thing you guys it
looks like a normal day but for these
few minutes from here in Nebraska from
11:30 to 2:30 or so bill I have to say
this I think I think you've given them
where I'm concerned about time here but
I think
you've given the best advice where you
said everybody just be in the moment I
think that's the best advice thank you
very much building if you want to make a
big one put a pinhole in a box that is
quite a moment somebody said you could
use a Ritz cracker too for the holidays
lots of choices thank you Bill and I